[Musique]
bonjour à tous
bonjour
aventuriers et aventurières
amoureux amoureuse de l'inconnu on est
très content d'être devant vous
aujourd'hui j'espère que vous allez bien
aujourd'hui on va aborder le thème
embrasser l'inconnu
embrasser l'inconnu c'est une attitude
qu'on peut retrouver chez les grands
explorateurs maritime du xvème xvième
siècle qui sillonné les mers pendant des
mois à la recherche d'un objectif
imaginer dès le milieu de la mer
imaginez l'entreprise que c est les
préparatifs dont on a besoin pour vous
dire que embrasser l'inconnu ce n'est
pas un acte spontané c'est un acte qui
se prépare pas moi juste qui part avec
mon petit baluchon trois barres de
céréales et qui va embrasser l'inconnu
embrasser l'inconnu ce n'est pas une
finalité
en fait embrasser l'inconnu
du problème technique
tempier embrasser l'inconnu à
voile a embrassé l'inconnu en fait c'est
une résultante la résultante d'une
volonté d'atteindre une destination un
objectif donc il y avoue qui souhaitait
atteindre une destination et entre sept
destinations cet objectif et vous il y a
votre inconnu il peut se passer plein de
choses durant ce voyage vous pouvez
comme christophe colomb souhaité aller
aux indes est arrivé en amérique
et au final le champ des possibles est
grand il peut arriver plein de choses et
pour vous donner un exemple plus récent
on va vous parler de notre expérience de
notre expérience nadir et moi dans
l'entrepreneuriat une autre manière dont
nous avons lancé notre start up camiade
pour vous donner un peu de contexte donc
nous sommes quatre amis de longue date
on s'est rencontrés sur les bancs de
l'université à grenoble en 2011 on avait
beaucoup de points en commun mais parmi
les points communs que nous avions il y
avait cet amour de l'entrepreneuriat je
me souviens de discussion qui ne
finissait pas avec nadir sur
l'entrepreneuriat sur ce que l'on
pourrait faire et il y avait cet amour
de l'impact avoir un impact positif
autour de nous et entre notre groupe
d'amis et ses deux volontés il y avait
une autre inconnue
nous avons commencé cette aventure
entrepreneuriale une aventure vers
l'inconnu avec l'épi ce qu'on appelle le
l'or rouge le safran afghans pourquoi le
safran en provenance d'afghanistan tout
d'abord parce que mon associé et surtout
mon ami est d'origine afghane avec un
très fort ancrage là bas et ce safran
est source d énormément d'espoir pour le
pays la première des choses qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le safran afghan a été
primé sur les dernières années
meilleures safran du monde c'est une
épice exceptionnelle à safran d'une
qualité incroyable mais surtout il est
cultivé par des hommes et des femmes
incroyables il faut savoir que le safran
est source d'un pacte ce que nous
souhaitons c'est d'être des
entrepreneurs impact est le premier
impact car le safran pour l'afghanistan
il faut savoir que 90% de l'opium
mondial provient d'afghanistan et 85%
l'héroïne qu'on retrouve ici en europe
provient d'afghanistan c'est un réel
fléau ici et là bas et pourtant le
safran est une réelle alternative fort
des scènes face à la culture du pavot à
opium le deuxième impact qu'a le safran
c'est sur la crise de l'emploi est
habilité des femmes afghanes en effet on
retrouve près de 80% du travail de
production qui est effectué par des
femmes c'est une réelle porte d'entrée à
l'employabilité des femmes et nous chez
camus et ben on souhaite aller bien plus
loin
retrouvez les femmes n'ont pas seulement
dans le travail de production mais à
différents maillons de la chaîne de
valeur dans le management la qualité la
logistique ou bien même le marketing
cela leur permettra carrément
l'indépendance financière et enfin le
dernier un pacte le safran répond à une
partie de la question de la crise
migratoire on retrouve près de 2 5
millions de réfugiés afghans à travers
le monde et quand on fait un zoom sur
cette population se rend compte que la
jeunesse quitte son pays car elle n'a
connu son pays que par la guerre la
misère le narcotrafic et le terrorisme
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui
nous a marqué avec abderrahmane quand
vous tapez sur google afghanistan on ne
voit que des emd images de désolation
pourtant c'est un pays qui est riche par
ses hommes et par ces femmes une fois
qu'on s'est dit tout ça on se retrouve
quatre amis de longue date voulant faire
du safran l'espoir pour le monde de
demain et cette histoire remplie
d'inconnus nous avons dû tracer et
marché à travers cet inconnu et gravir a
connu après inconnue va commencer la
première inconnue que nous avons
rencontrés c'était nous sortions d'école
nous étions jeunes diplômés et nous ne
savions pas si l'entrepreneuriat était
pour nous le salariat la deuxième
inconnue s'est très vite nous avons
compris pour un projet d'une telle
ampleur qu'il fallait être 100% focus et
donc démissionner et donc prendre un
risque la troisième inconnue c'était que
nous allions travailler avec
l'afghanistan c'est un pays
géopolitiquement instable nous sommes
posé plusieurs questions
est-ce que nous avons les épaules est-ce
que nous sommes faits pour ça et oui la
réponse était oui nous avions l'intimé
conviction de devenir des entrepreneurs
du changement et un pacte est notre
métier trouve tout son sens dans des
moments de difficulté la quatrième est
inconnu pour tout entrepreneur qui veut
développer un projet c'est les finances
nous en avions aucune
5e a connu enfin c'est celle du marché
vous avez beau avoir le plus beau projet
du monde le plus beau produit ou du
monde la meilleure équipe si le marché
répond pas votre projet tombe à l'eau et
au final on se retrouve quatre amis à
vouloir lancer leur premier produit leur
premier projet et toutes ces inconnues
nous les avons vécues comme des marches
chacun connu c'était une marche à gravir
et cette histoire entrepreneuriale est
un peu résumé par la phrase d'un célèbre
aviateur homme américain qui disait que
plus on s'imprègne on rentre dans
l'inconnu plus il nous paraît immense
est merveilleux c'est ce qui nous
arrivait dans l'entrepreneuriat une
inconnue après l'autre on se rendait
compte du chemin que nous avons accompli
mais surtout de l'impact qu'on pouvait
aller chercher c'est ce qui était beau
maintenant je reviens en décembre 2019 à
notre dernière inconnue qui était la
mise sur le marché
donc en décembre 2019 on commence à
vendre nos premiers grammes de safran et
on appelle nos clients deux mois après
avoir effectué la vente on les appelle
oui bonjour comment est ce que vous
trouvez notre safran et on a toujours
les mêmes retour votre safran ils
excellent sont bons les beaux l'histoire
elle est belle je l'aimé bien au chaud
dans mon placard et je l'utiliserai à un
moment exceptionnel nous ça nous faisait
plaisir à rappeler la personne de mois
après alors qu'ils ont utilisé le safran
moment exceptionnel il n'est pas encore
arrivé et au final on s'est très vite
rendu compte que les personnes n'étaient
pas habitués à utiliser notre safran est
en réalité on a confronté cette habitude
de nos clients à notre modèle économique
et à notre volonté d'impact et on s'est
dit on arrive devant un obstacle
l'obstacle c'est que les utilisateurs ne
glisse pas non sont pas habitués à
étudier notre safran et on a dû faire
quelque chose
que les entrepreneurs sont habitués à
faire et doivent faire c'est primordial
ça s'appelle pivoter le pivot
c'est une chose que chaque entrepreneur
doit faire et doit garder en tête qu'est
ce que le pivot le pivot c'est vous
menez votre navire dans une direction
vous faites face à un obstacle vous ne
trouvez pas les réponses soit vous
changez de cap soit vous couler le
navire est très clairement c'est ce qui
arrivé avec camilla ben parce que soit
on arrivait à intéresser et à pousser
les gens à prendre et à utiliser le
safran soit au final autre modèle d'un
pack ne pouvait fonctionner c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons pu voter
à la base on s'orientait vers les
bienfaits culinaire de les pisse
et on a pivoté et on a décidé d'aller
vers les bienfaits thérapeutiques du
safran leur rouge a de nombreux
bienfaits pour le corps c'est un anti
stress naturel il facilite le sommeil
c'est une réponse pour les troubles
menstruels que rencontrent les femmes
ils préparent ils règlent les troubles
liés à la ménopause à la santé sexuelle
etc c'est un cadeau de la nature pour le
corps humain et donc nous avons décidé
nous orienter vers les bienfaits
thérapeutiques de cette épice en créant
une marque de compléments alimentaires
qui s'appelle nahalie
et après avoir développé cette marque de
compléments alimentaires et comme
toujours on aime on a aimé en tout cas
dans notre projet on aime toujours être
accompagné par des experts et confronter
nos idées et un challenge et afin d'être
sûr d'aller dans la bonne direction donc
on a présenté notre projet notre marque
de compléments alimentaires un expert on
a dit voilà on aimerait votre retour sur
notre projet elle nous a écouté avec
attention et cette histoire m'a vraiment
touché parce que cette personne nous a
dit ok c'est bien vous avez un beau
projet un très beau modèle d'impact un
très beau modèle de société une belle
équipe une tête plutôt bien fait
pourtant vous visez x chiffre d'affaires
à l'horizon 2025
dit cette personne me dit vous êtes sûr
de viser ce chiffre d'affaires je lui
dis oui elle me répond mais avec tout ça
avec cette histoire vous savez que une
pizzeria bien placés dans paris fait le
même chiffre d'affaires est là ces
paroles m'a fait l'effet d'un coup de
poignard non pas que cette personne
dévaloriser les pizzerias d'ailleurs moi
je suis un fan de pizzas et mais plutôt
que cette personne vous voulez que
briser nos barrières mentales de nous
dire viser plus haut aller plus haut en
visant plus haut qu'est ce qui se passe
on construit des fondations beaucoup
plus solide et le chemin afin
d'atteindre cet objectif là parsemée
d'inconnues devient beaucoup plus clair
et donc nous sommes partis d'une marque
de compléments alimentaires ultra niché
à un concept qu'on a appelé la safrane
aux thérapies et ce pivot il est tout à
fait prêts récents et si nous n'étions
pas une start up nous n'aurions pu
aborder ce pivot manière sereine je vais
faire un petit récapitulatif en 2011 on
s'est connus sur les bancs de la fac des
jeunes étudiants
ensuite 2019 on lance cas miam 2020 le
complément alimentaire
2021 on est sur la safrane aux thérapies
c'est un plaisir de partager avec vous
cette aventure entrepreneuriale la
manière dont nous avons entrepris dans
l'inconnu et on souhaiterait avant de
finir vous laisser quelques clés pour
vous permettre à vos tours
d'entreprendre dans l'inconnu la
première clé que j'aimerais partager
avec vous aujourd'hui c'est dans votre
voyage il est important quand vous
commencerez à entreprendre dans
l'inconnu de fortifier la base de la
pyramide de maslow la base de la
pyramide de maslow c'est les besoins
physiologiques les besoins du corps
dormir manger se loger
et si vous ne sécurisé pas ses besoins
physiologiques et que vous vous lancer
dans cette aventure entrepreneuriale
vous allez souffrir ça va être compliqué
pour vous l'idée de l'entrepreneur qui
travaillent de minuit à 6 heures du
matin qui dort dans le garage de son ami
qui se nourrit de nouilles à 50 centimes
ça c'est un cliché et le fait de
d'entreprendre de cette manière là vous
n'allez pas durer pensez aux grands
explorateurs maritime qui préparé leur
voyage soyez préparés
le deuxième conseil c'est l'itération
entreprendre dans l'inconnu embrasser
l'inconnu ça se fait pas par pas un pas
après un autre vous embrasser l'inconnu
ce qui était inconnu devient connu vous
capitaliser sur ce que vous avez appris
découvert et vous ne vous arrêtez pas là
vous allez plus loin vous continuez à
avancer et ça c'est important et
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce qu'au
final toute personne qui a embrassé
l'inconnu c'est que c'est un procès ce
qui est douloureux ce n'est pas simple
vous faites violence en voulant sortir
de votre zone de confort et je me
souviens de cette fois âne à dire où
nous souhaitions en fait on nous avait
dit vous avez un safran magnifique allée
voir les chefs étoilés de lyon voit les
chefs étoilés d'accord on va aller voir
les chefs étoilés c'est un monde qu'on
ne connaissait pas du tout mais jamais
mis nos quais dans un restaurant étoilé
donc on dit on va y aller on a pris un
peu de safran on hasard on a mis dans la
fiole on appris la fiole on a mis ici on
à aller dans un des fameux restaurant à
lyon on arrive devant la porte gros
blocage la marche elle est là on nage at
on n'est jamais rentré dans un
restaurant étoilé maintenant il faut et
rentrait pas pour être client mais pour
vendre quelque chose et la marshall
était haute et on a tourné autour du
restaurant pendant 20 minutes avant de
trouver le courage de rentrer on se
regardait bien à vienna 4 qui font de
meilleurs chemise à ou à la fin on a dit
on y va on est rentré on a rencontré une
personne super gentille on lui a dit on
souhaite voir le chef la personne nous a
dit non ça marche pas comme ça faut
prendre rendez vous avec le chef et au
final à nous à ramener quelqu'un en
cuisine et on lui a dit on a quelque
chose à vous montrer on a du super bon
safran et là j'ai l'impression j'ai
l'impression de vendre autre chose
et donc l'allemand on est rentré
bredouille avec notre safran et on a
compris que c'est pas de cette manière
là qu'il faut avancer c'est pas de cette
manière là qu'il faut procéder et donc
on a capitalisé
donc c'est très important
d'avancer pas parfait à capitaliser et
continuer à avancer
la troisième clé ou conseil que non que
nous avons ce sont ce soir cet après
midi c'est d'avancer objectif après
objectif de ne pas avoir plusieurs
objectifs ne pas courir après plusieurs
lièvres sinon on se retrouve tout
simplement dans une nébuleuse d'inconnus
ce qui fait que vous n'a sans vous
n'avancez pas dans vos projets et la 4e
clé
c'est quitte à partir à l aventure
pour ma part je préfère y aller
accompagner c'est la raison pour
laquelle est choisi d associer des amis
la raison aussi pour laquelle nous avons
été accompagnés par des structures des
structures d'accompagnement dans
l'entreprenariat et au final
ces structures ces personnes ses amis
nous ont aidé à gravir les marches nous
avons encore beaucoup d'inconnues
auxquels nous faisons face au quotidien
mais ces marches là ce qui est important
pour vous comme pour moi c'est qu' il ne
faut pas que la peur de l'inconnu vous
disent très de ce qui est connu merci à
toutes
[Musique]